hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm going to
explain a science fiction movie from
fringe series seasons 4 called forced
perspective
for your information this is an
anthology series so the plot has no
correlation with the previous episode
the movie begins with a teenage girl
named emily mallum who is drawing across
the street of boston
she suddenly gets dizzy and immediately
draws a sketch of an unknown person in
her sketchbook after she finishes the
drawing she chases after the man who is
walking across the street with his
co-worker and hands him the drawing
they walk past a construction site where
a steel beam falls from the crane and
impales him in the chest
the woman opens the sketch from emily
and is very shocked as it somehow
accurately predicts the death of the man
one of the officers lincoln calls
detective olivia and informs her about
the incident
she later orders him to collect all the
surveillance from the area to identify
the girl
meanwhile olivia returns home and turns
out that his father jim mallum is aware
of her gifted ability and has been
moving his family around the country to
keep the secret from the public
the next day lincoln successfully
identifies the girl and tracks her move
but somehow still cannot figure out
where she lives
back to emily she is riding on a bus
when she suddenly gets a vision again
and sketches one of the passengers but
the man quickly gets off the bus
emily tries to follow him hoping that
she can give the sketch to him as a
warning but the man disappears from her
sight after going door-to-door the
agents finally arrive at mallum's home
and show jim emily's picture but jim and
the other family members lie to them
claiming that they don't know her
just after the agents leave the building
they coincidentally meet emily on the
street and start asking questions
regarding his ability to predict
someone's death but the enraged father
runs out of the building and drags emily
away from them
jim reveals that they live as nomads to
avoid a corporation called massive
dynamic that tries to kidnap her
daughter and study her ability olivia
gives jim her business card offering to
help them if the corporation threatens
them again
afterward olivia confronts the executive
director of massive dynamic named nina
sharp and questions him about emily
she admits that the company has put a
huge interest in her
moments later the agent receives a call
from emily who wants to meet her face to
face
olivia finds emily at a nearby lakeside
where the gifted girl shows her the
sketch that she drew on the bus earlier
the sketch visualizes a pile of dead
bodies and building debris around the
bodies
olivia brings the girl to a lab where
emily reveals her ability she gets the
vision to be exact images of someone's
death in her mind when she sees a nearby
person who is about to die
she continues that she always tries to
prevent the incident from happening but
the visions always come true
she is also afraid that the massacre is
going to happen
the agents immediately attempt to
identify the man on the bus who turns
out to be albert duncan
olivia also invites jim to come over to
the lab
to get a broader view about the incident
in the sketch lincoln suggests walter
hypnotize emily allowing her to recall
the vision
in her mind emily is brought back to the
bus
she walks out of the bus and is
terrified when she encounters a lot of
people who are frozen in time trying to
run away from an explosion
unfortunately some of them are dead just
as depicted in the sketch
as she walks through them she finds a
sign and informs everyone in the lab
she also manages to spot duncan's dead
body who is holding a detonator one of
the guys recognizes the sign and informs
olivia that the incident will take place
in the courthouse
after that jim and emily return home
where the father spots the same black
van he saw in the previous house and
tells his daughter to pack her bag
realizing that duncan is going to blow
up the courthouse bomb squad is
immediately deployed
meanwhile duncan is present at the
courthouse and demands to meet judge
o'malley as everyone is evacuated the
bomb squad discovers a set of bombs in
the parking lot however it will take too
long for them to disarm the bomb so
peter gets the idea to block the
specific radio frequency which will
prevent the detonator from working
back to duncan he eventually meets the
judge who ruled against duncan in a
child custody case and accuses him for
ruining his life
he presses the detonator but nothing
happens a few moments later the fbi
including olivia arrives and surrounds
duncan he reveals that he has backup
bombs wrapped in his body but olivia
manages to calm him down and duncan
eventually withdraws his intention to
blow himself up
duncan is then arrested and everyone is
safe
back at the house emily disappears and
jim thinks she has been kidnapped
however the agents confirm that the
black van is just a dry-cleaning van
olivia and lincoln find the girl at the
lakeside where emily sits in the cold
olivia notices the sketch beside emily
showing emily with her dad sitting on
the same bench at the same time jim
arrives and sits beside her daughter
with olivia watching them just as
depicted
the father embraces emily as she dies
from a stroke that resulted from the
overload of electrical activity in her
brain
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching